since the cuban missile crisis the world
has benefited from a largely peaceful
status quo
among all of the major world powers
today that stability is being challenged
in each of the three most critical areas
of the world
in east asia china is aggressively
asserting claims
over maritime areas on its periphery
claims that conflict sharply with those
of its neighbors
and the beijing regime gives much
indication of believing
that its natural destiny is to be the
dominant power in all of the western
pacific which would mean over all of the
nations on its periphery
in the persian gulf iran aspires to
establish persian hegemony over the
region
and the organization that styles itself
the islamic state is seeking to overturn
the entire order in that region
but in some ways most troubling of all
have been vladimir putin's actions in
ukraine
which have violated one of the most
fundamental post-cold war security
agreements
the 1994 agreement under which ukraine
agreed
to surrender its nuclear weapons in
exchange for commitments by russia the
united states and the united kingdom
commitments to ukraine's independence
and territorial integrity
moreover putin has done so by invoking a
rationale of protecting ethnic russians
in other countries that could be applied
elsewhere in central and eastern europe
with results that could be
extraordinarily dangerous and
destabilizing
some twenty years ago
when boris yeltsin is president of the
russian federation
made his first first visit to washington
i was in his meeting with then secretary
of defense dick cheney
i have never forgotten yeltsin's
response when the subject of soviet
plans to increase defense spending was
raised
to increase soviet defense spending he
said would be a crime against the soviet
people
who have already suffered enough under
70 years of communism
what a different view of russia's past
from putin's declaration
to the collapse of the soviet union was
a major geopolitical disaster
these two very different perspectives on
russia's past are each connected to very
different visions of russia's future
the one perspective welcomes the escape
from russia's dark tyrannical past
and welcomes the vision of a free and
truly democratic russia as a part of
europe
a europe to which russia has contributed
some of its greatest writers and
composers
artists and scientists
a europe which russia had been
approaching even under the tsars
before the tragedy of world war one
and the subsequent communist takeover
drove a wedge between western and
eastern europe that endured for seven
decades
the other perspective sees russia with a
distinctly eurasian identity
and views democracy from a perspective
that would be comfortable for asian
autocrats
putin's aggression in ukraine is as much
about cementing his hold on power in
russia
as it is about the interests of ethnic
russians in ukraine
the prospect of a ukraine that had
thrown out a corrupt dictator
and might become a successful democracy
integrated with europe
was threatening to putin
because the appeal of europe is still
powerful in russia itself
and because it threatens him when
russians are able to think
about the wealth being accumulated by
putin and his friends
but when the issue becomes instead one
of raw nationalism
putin's popularity increases
that appeal to raw nationalism has been
a pattern since the beginning of his
national career
whether in chechnya
or in georgia or in abkhazia or in
southeast asia
and now again with crimea
you